sandra comment ça va ça va et toi sandra
ton nom est bond
record depuis la messe quoi par un
record de rapidité
se remet à la réforme en vas tu ma
chérie je fais comment allez vous
comment allez-vous kent yuv où elle a
commencé quand même que c'est comme bull
sans classe en mal
mais je te vends des pleins d'espoir en
elle
super je vais partir et je vais revenir
et on marque et doit prendre à coups de
jets d'affaires et l'entrée tu ne m'as
pas veux tu ne sais pas qui je suis et
tu applaudis forains
est ce que tu peux me lancer est ce que
tu peux annoncer pour le public ok merci
je m'en tiens
voici le grand le meilleur de la targo
demande accueillie et maintenant à m
bami
[Applaudissements]
tu apprends la colaition traînons un
soudard
j'aime la france je suis vraiment
franco-français donc la démarrer part de
l'allemand sera pas faire
la règle et reste concentré c'est de
l'anglais sam et des franco tunisiens on
y pense toujours à la limite tu me fais
un truc en arabe mais pas touche à
un
bon la barbe
les passionnés le plus grand le plus
beau alors sous vos options mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs accueillez le
grand le bord le muscle tout ce que vous
voulez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne année en fait l'émission la parole
est libre
et c'est ça qui fait notre succès matin
puis des années merci d'être là dit
chéri vous le savez quand ça va les
chroniqueurs
super ils sont géniaux mais pas payés
sont sympas salue son salut si je suis
vraiment heureux de te voir ce soir tu
peux me tutoyez hockey avec grand
plaisir sandra merci alors que tu as
quel âge tendre on peut donner ce que tu
très jeune j'ai 30 ans 30 ans tu es
célibataire maintenant je suis un pied
dedans un pied dehors d'accord on
payable par ap froid
[Rires]
je te le dis et donc d'un pied dehors en
p2 venant avec cette personne que tu as
rencontré d'anciens exacte avec qui
d'accord par contre si tu trouve
quelqu'un qui te plaît tu peux peut-être
voilà je laisse la porte ouverte comme
d'accord l'apport qu'elle est ouverte
comment c'est à dire elle est
entrouverte ces cinq éléments mal à la
trouver alors portons trouvait alors
qu'un pied
et toi tu es comme
ça on peut dire les choses comme alors
voilà donc s'en va voilà c'est important
de le savoir